well we were talking about chief
diversity officer so i want to get over
to our next story here
uh you guys are going to love this one
oh boy
we have a new woke ad actually we got a
couple but we're going to start start
with this one i'm so excited from from
libs of tick tock we have a doritos
commercial oh and it says doritos just
put out this ad for your viewing
pleasure i will now play the ad for you
and then we will discuss
this will break you
here
all right not everybody's watching so
i'm going to translate
for you guys it's in spanish
an old lady and a bunch of people are
looking at a shrine and there is a photo
of an old man who says my brother i miss
you so much
[Music]
oh now there's blue smoke
and a ghost appears
[Music]
what's up family stan how are you guys
all right all right now all of a sudden
another man has just emerged behind i
think what would you call them are they
was that a lich
is he a little oh yeah a what a lich
what's a lich i don't know what it
it's like is zombie but not mindless
right oh i think he's a spirit because
this is based on the movie coco yeah oh
is it yeah it's based on the idea of the
day of the dead right right so he's he's
a he's a uh is it the most
yeah yeah he's he's a he's a poltergeist
yeah he's a he's a spirit he's not a
poltergeist
guys no maybe he'd be a poltergeist if
he was but hold on okay a man has just
emerged from behind him he removes his
hat he removes his hat
[Music]
who
[Music]
[Music]
so look at his hands he's got his arms
are bones uh so weird is that is that
what coco is i guess yeah yeah think
that's something that is very similar to
the style yeah
okay let me i just gotta say right off
the bat doritos what what does this have
to do you know guys i really want some i
really want some chips yeah i don't know
i saw his commercial i'm not gonna eat
that that high glycemic garbage ghost
garbage
hold on hold on i don't i'm i would i
got no issue with a psa about respecting
people who love anybody or whatever or
the dead person yeah exactly or the dead
remember but just i what i can't
understand is why they summon a dead man
who then also brings with him his
undead gay partner yeah and why that is
selling
chips corn chips yeah yeah also
eat corn chips if you're dead maybe if
you're dead i mean you also aren't
supposed to have relations if you're
dead i think you're dead
so many questions
is this what they think the afterlife is
like like
you're a skeleton but you have a
mustache he just
he wasn't gay in life and then after he
died he became gay
my take on it was that he was too
ashamed to tell his family
in life checks out that he was that he
was gay and so now he's able to say that
because he's dead have you guys ever
seen the movie the others no no nicole
kidman no really no it's an old movie
i'm gonna spoil it but it's really good
if it's old that's fine basically it's
like this old-timey like 1800s or
whatever and weird haunting things keep
happening and you know like doors are
opening and stuff and then like they see
they see a little girl and they're like
freaking out and there's ghosts
and then it turns out that actually
they're the ghosts the whole oh that's
crazy and the weird things happening
were the living people doing stuff and
nicole kidman just couldn't like
reconcile the fact that she's like a
ghost or whatever and so i'm like i'm
imagining a horror film like that
but it turns out like at the end like
the twist was that the ghost was gay the
whole time
i'm just like i don't under it's it's
it's weird because they're weird it's
not thematically making sense well
they're gay and they're attracted to
dead people that's another thing
technically each of those guys is
independent more of the mainstreaming of
kink yeah yeah right
there was a an advice letter in slate
magazine about someone wrote in saying
that their kink was necrophilia oh my
gosh that is disgusting why can't we
just start saying the word perversion
again we have to like it's not a cake
that's a conversion
basically answered that
it's okay
oh my god it's not it's not it's not
okay it's really not okay still at work
because the person worked at a funeral
home oh my oh my oh my god
that took like a second to really sink
in with me but wow
oh boy yeah cool with this
so what do what what a world we're in
this is a doritos commercial
what happened but this this meme has
been around for a while
like where you know companies
are trying to this is the thing about a
chief diversity officer right they're
betting on selling their product based
on
yeah
ideas
they're betting on selling they're
betting on selling more doritos to woke
people and betting that conservatives
don't care yeah conservatives don't care
and you know that's part of it too is
conservatives for the most part are just
like meh i still like to read yeah
whatever
we gotta start filming skits cause we
can make a great one where it's like
this we just make a really ridiculous
religious commercial and then it's
selling something like like you know lug
nuts for your tire right like it has
nothing to do a dad comes like comes
back home to like meet his son and his
son's like you weren't there for me and
mom and then he's like but thanks to
these
meyer's lug nuts i was able to finally
make it home and he's like dad and they
hug and then like too much time a ghost
comes out of the chimney
the ghost comes out of the chimney and
the closet at the same time explains to
them that he has a partner in the
afterlife
yo
that's yeah i would say that's a bit of
a strange commercial
yeah not a big fan i'm not either i'm
not a fan of the commercial do we have
to worry about though do we have i'd
call an exorcist no listen
to me if this is what this is coming for
everything it's interesting too because
so
several years ago i was uh walking in
i don't know where was it somewhere in
manhattan and the subway station there
were all these advertisements and i was
with my son who at the time i think was
five
and there was a huge ad of people
making out right it was just a it was
just a print ad but it was giant like
the subway the subway yeah and um my son
goes
um mom
what's that an ad for you're like cpr
they're doing mouth come out cpr class
and we looked at it for a while and i
said hun that's an ad for jeans
and he was like what passing them on
apparently yeah what jeans
and he was like that is so peculiar and
this is like the five-year-old the
five-year-old very peculiar it used to
be that they were selling us things with
sex right right fine and now they're
selling us things with their new
religion it's like the
family guys that joke where it's like
they're watching tv and there's a bunch
of beautiful women at a pool
and they're all drinking and getting
drunk and it's like drink our beer if
you do beautiful women love sex that's
south park yeah or no i know something
like that okay i know south park did a
version where they keep going they're
like yeah drink all these women
drink responsibly
absolutely i always think that too it's
like well you remember the ones then
they would have a boat and i was always
like i would drink the beer if it got me
the boat yeah but i know it but it does
it well so this is this is one thing i
learned i went to art school oh and i
took a media literacy theory class
and one thing our professor did is he
just had us watch a bunch of commercials
and they almost never have anything to
do with the product ever the reason
these are weird is because they're
clearly pushing a specific ideology
which is pretty strange doing an
advertisement to like support a
political cause that has nothing to do
with the product but usually they want
to sell people an experience so the idea
is you associate their product with
something positive so
he would show us in particular these uh
kraft mac and cheese commercials and
they were really insidious because they
were playful but basically the moral of
every commercial was someone in your
family is betraying you like all the
commercial you wouldn't think it that
way watching that but you watch all the
commercials and it stacks up and the
punch line is always like someone in
your family secretly screwed you over to
get the macaroni um oh that's creepy
yeah it was actually really cool it was
very funny sounds like my family
what's interesting is commercials always
try to sell you an experience
and then the product is secondary i
remember when i was a kid hold on i have
to tell this story really fast because
this is something that was very vivid
for me because they used to sell these
like rocket pops freezer pops and in
these commercials the world was always
black and white it was very boring this
kid is going to the fridge nothing's
going on it's highly uninteresting you
take out one of these super cool rocket
pops and you lick it and the whole world
is like in color i was like six so when
i actually finally convinced my mom to
get these stupid rocket pop things i was
like this is gonna be amazing and i
licked it and i was like oh everything i
know is a lie because nothing happened
yeah it's very sad it's like it worked
on a kid right oh 100 i remember they
had commercials for a drink called i
believe was called tang yeah and in the
commercial they'd like put the straw in
the drink and then the camera would go
through the straw and they'd be like
chimpanzees on surfboards
it was crazy and so my brother pat was
like you know like i actually looked
inside i got to get tangled so i looked
inside and like that's literally what's
happening i was like no dude no way i
was pretty little i was like no wait so
then i was walking
at the park and i saw this like crumpled
up like gross empty tank with the straw
in it i was like looking through it
i was like
chimpanzees
i was like there's no there's literally
not a single chip i would have been fine
with one chimpanzee surface isn't that
though what the astronauts took to space
didn't they have tang in space so
astronauts did have those pouches they
had those weird spots
yeah but it's not a you know just to
what you were saying before about
pushing a political idea on us it's not
a political idea that they're pushing
it's cultural this is that's both yeah i
i suppose well it's both i think i think
it's different i think politics i think
politics can they the two can have an
impact on each other but i think what's
being pushed is a cultural
transformation it's so hard for me to
separate the two because disrupting the
family is a huge
strategy for political control thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you